Welcome back everyoneit's Charlie.
This will be my full Lord of the Rings
the Rings of Power episode 6 video there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so we'll
break it all down sorry watch continues but we did
get a lot of backstory a lot of questions answered
so if you're new to the channel I'm doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them and careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shop by
shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as
we go along starting with the episode titled udun
which is a reference to Mordor that's the Elven
word for hell too like because of the eruption
everything looks like it's hell like they are in
Hell the actual opening scene is adar's Gauntlet
at hand digging through the dirt planting some
seeds which we find out from Iran deer's character
later is part of the Elven tradition that goes
back to the original elves because we find out
the Adar is one of those original elves that was
stolen by morgoth so that means the tradition of
planting the seeds like planting new life before
a bunch of life is lost during a battle goes way
back to the beginning of their race he calls the
Orcs his children and refers to them as if he's
one of them because as he explains later in the
episode he was one of those original elves stolen
by morgoth and twisted to Darkness like Galadriel
refers to them as the children of the dark so if
it wasn't clear he was calling himself an orc
but I think that's because he's like gen 1 Orcs
And what I think they're trying to say through
the show through this new backstory that they're
creating is that when Mor God did that the elves
that he stole at first all looked kind of like
Adar look like they have the darkened skin but
they still look kind of like elves and through
the many many hundreds thousands of generations
over thousands of years you get to the modern
Orcs And they just mutated slowly over time like
their biology has slowly changed through all the
different generations and that's why some of them
here are probably very literally biologically his
descendants you also probably noticed the river
that's on his armor is similar to the river on
gilgallad's Armor too it's not clear what river
that might be if you think you know what it is
write it below in the comments but I think that's
meant to be a reference to those original groups
of elves the original tribes of elves before the
call of the Valar before some of them answered the
call went to valinor and became the noldor elves
so we've talked about how Galadriel is basically
like one of the oldest elves that's alive during
this part of the timeline let's use thousands and
thousands of years old at this point but because
she comes from the elves that actually answered
the call of the Ballon d'Or she's part of the
noldor elves that means that she was actually
born way after Adar was so Adar technically the
oldest person that we know of next to someone like
Sauron because we know sauron's going to show up
eventually technically the Valar the Maiar would
be way way older than anybody that was actually
born on the planet itself when he mentions the
Edward mithrin that's the Elven word for the gray
mountains and when he mentions effin Arnon that's
another word for this area here between where
Gondor and Mordor will sit now like obviously
Gondor doesn't exist yet but it's built by isildur
and his father and their people the faithful that
come to live on Middle Earth I'm sure there'll be
some references to that in future seasons of the
show at some point when he says that they used to
be unnamed slaves and Far Away lands that's just a
reference to the way that their race was scattered
after moraga's defeat and after it sounds like he
killed Sauron because as he says in the episode I
killed him I split him open but obviously he just
killed his physical body because we know he has
to come back the only reason why Frodo was able to
destroy him is because Sauron had bound his life
force to the one ring of power and they destroyed
the one ring of power in Mount Doom so thus they
were able to destroy Sauron but at this point in
the timeline because the rings of power haven't
been created yet when you kill someone like sorry
like a Maiar Gandalf is another good example of
this too their Spirit just goes back into its
Cosmic State they can still inhabit other bodies
like they can still be kicked onto the board so to
speak that's how Gandalf dies during his battle
with the balrog and then comes back as Gandalf
the White so it sounds like when Adar killed
Sauron his Spirit just transferred to another
form there were so many references to Sauron and
people's conversations in this episode I'll Point
them out as we get to those different parts of the
episode but they basically wanted to confirm that
Adar is not meant to be a version of Sauron he
hated Sauron like he says that he tried to kill
him and it's all because he wanted to protect
his people the other Orcs Soren was trying to
kill them in his experiments trying to harness the
power of the Unseen World and a lot of that is a
reference to the actual one ring of power like he
says Sauron was missing something he was missing
the One Ring of Power that's why every time Frodo
and Bilbo really anyone would put on the One Ring
of Power they're able to perceive the Unseen realm
the Unseen World is sort of like this other layer
of reality that's made up of pure magic that only
really powerful like Maiar Valar illuvitar elves
can perceive and it sounds like Soren was looking
for a conduit to harness all the power of that
realm and obviously that winds up becoming the One
Ring of Power he uses that to harness the power of
the Unseen World one of the really cool things
too is that when he was explaining that Sauron
backstory in the special Forge when you're looking
at all the skulls melted into the walls like all
the experiments that failed one of them is the
skull of a balrog one of the other cool things
too at the beginning of the episode when he's
addressing his army here before their first big
attack is that he name drops female Orcs as well
which we haven't seen much of like he says they're
brothers and sisters Peter Jackson actually
explained one of the reasons why you don't
see a ton of female Orcs running around especially
in The Lord of the Rings movies that he made the
whole idea is that they reproduce like rabbits
like there are hordes hordes of Orcs in order
to accomplish that all the female Orcs basically
have to be constantly pregnant so basically that's
why you don't see a lot of the female Orcs
because they're busy having more orc babies
you hear them speak in the black speech which is
the main language of Mordor but this is actually
like a special new language that Sauron created
a long time ago as a common tongue for all of
his servants to use not just Orcs like every race
that served him in Mordor eventually the word that
they keep chanting nampat I believe means to take
back or to seize which I think just flows with the
whole idea of them seizing the Southlands when
he says the iron hand of the Uruk that's also
what the Orcs call themselves their own race
the urukai are sort of like super Orcs they're
like Orcs bred with humans because Normal Orcs are
just a little bit smaller so when you see like the
really giant Orcs like there's one in the episode
that's probably like a half orc half ogre or half
troll the regular old Orcs tend to be a little bit
smaller I think the reason why they use the tower
to trick the Orcs and bring it down around them is
because they wanted to Swerve on their version of
a battle of the Helms Deep like they didn't want
it to be a total copy of Helm's Deep because a lot
of the circumstances are similar you have this
small group of people against an insurmountable
Force Of Orcs but you have a bunch of
reinforcements arriving and a wizard arriving with
the harfoots so I think that's why they wanted to
make the battle feel as different as possible but
it was much smaller scale than I was expecting
like the actual battle is over pretty quickly
but there are two episodes left so we'll see like
those aren't the only Orcs that are around on the
planet right now when Galadriel gives that whole
speech to aseel dirt about having humility saving
entire kingdoms that's meant to be foreshadowing
I think for the eventual War the last Alliance and
him eventually killing Sauron bearing the One
Ring of Power there are a couple references to
that later in the episode too when he says he
was trying to get away from numenor turns out
that's actually a pretty smart move because we
know the downfall will happen eventually so you
don't want to be anywhere near the island when
that happens but it sounds like that's going to
be a ways off I think him really wanting to leave
the island permanently is also a reference to him
eventually creating Gondor with his family they
mention and what happened to his mother a couple
times like they mentioned her previously in the
series but you don't know completely what happened
to her and I don't think there's a lot of book
Canon that explains her fate either a Lendale has
just kind of hinted at it a couple times they'll
probably give the rest of her backstory eventually
then when you see Miro they do all this battle
planning in the background you can see these sun
symbols all over everything they're all over their
armor like even Galadriel who's wearing numenorian
armor has that sun symbol on it I believe the
sun symbol is meant to represent the origins
of mankind itself like mankind first woke up so
to speak at the first rising of the sun which
happened after the years of trees because the
first actual Sunrise which Galadriel references
in the prologue to episode 1 didn't happen until
after morgoth and ungoliant destroyed the two
trees the whole thing with morgoth's sword being
so strong that Iran deer can't destroy I think
is another reference to the One Ring of Power only
being weak to the fires of Mount Doom like there's
some things that are built to be so powerful that
you can only destroy them in very special ways
it's not totally clear if the sword was created
directly by morgoth himself or by Sauron because
usually when you talk about creating things Soren
is the person who winds up making them because he
studied under allay whose specialty is creating
things that's why the dwarves Revere him so much
because he also literally created the dwarves
it's also how Sauron knew how to create the
rings of power then like I said the actual battle
happens and instead of doing it Battle of Helm's
Deep style they played a little bit more like a
Seven Samurai kind of battle they reference the
Seas that Bronwyn gave to Iran deer that he's
been keeping around his neck those are the same
types of flowers that you see all over the graves
in the two towers in Rohan they typically grow on
graves he also uses them later in the episode to
close up her wounds when he says they'll plant
the rest of them after the battle that's also a
reference to a bunch of people dying during the
battle because a lot of them grow on graves The
Valor that he references the one who watches over
growing things is probably yavana she's called
The Giver of fruits and queen of the earth you
notice early on in the episode here when they show
you the wide shot like before the battle begins
in the background you can clearly see Mountain
Doom just foreshadowing the end of the episode
the bigger WTF during the battle is they find out
that they basically just killed a lot of their
former comrades who had joined Adar like he used
them as cannon fodder which was actually pretty
clever for him to do then when the new minorians
arrive if you zoom and enhance on halbrand here
this is actually kind of weird notice how his
armor has rings all over it even his gauntlets
have rings all over them like literally his body
is covered in rings there are also a lot of Sauron
references in the conversations that he has later
in the episode after the battle so there's a lot
of moments during this where they really really
want you to think that he might be Sauron I'll
get to those in a second because it could totally
be a misdirect just in general though during this
big fight numenoreans have vastly Superior armor
and weaponry probably even training than the
southlanders even though some of the new minorians
are pretty green so to speak like it seems like
a sealder doesn't have a lot of fight training
when he almost winds up losing his father like
he comes rushing to him that's meant to be another
reference to the war of the last Alliance when the
exact same thing happened and he takes the broken
pieces of his father's sword and narsal and cuts
the one ring of power off of sauron's hand if you
remember a couple episodes ago when we saw inside
Muriel's father's room tar palantir it looks like
the narcile sword was actually in the background
we get that whole scene of Galadriel and halbrand
versus Adar notice how Halbrand is using the pole
arm which is very similar to sauron's Pole
weapon he even asked Adar if he remembers him
you remember me so they really want you to think
that Halbrand might be a saron's new form and he
might be getting some form of revenge against him
for killing him previously like this is what you
get for destroying my previous body when Adar
says he doesn't remember him that could also be
a reference to Sauron literally taking a different
form so that he looks different different physical
appearance like no you don't look familiar and
when he suggests he hurts someone that he loves
that could be a reference to morgoth but I don't
think that Adar would have hurt morgoth that's why
I think when he says he killed a wife or child
he's trying to say that he killed Halbrand's
family before this and even though there are
more scenes with Halbrand that kind of referenced
Sauron after this like they still want you to
wonder because they're two episodes left I still
kinda think that it's a misdirect isildur and his
friends joke about heading to the mountains meant
to be foreshadowing for the end of the episode
because minutes after this Mount Doom literally
erupts then they confirm most of my theories about
adar's origin the original Orcs what happened with
morgoth in that first group that he stole when
she uses the word moriander to describe the Orcs
I couldn't find a direct ref reference to that
word but it might just translate to something
like dark elves because she also later mentions
Dark Elves like she calls them the sons of the
dark I already explained his story about what
happened to Sauron after the war of Wrath and
why he literally might now be wearing a new face
the other really cool thing too is when he refers
to him as the one you call Sauron as an Adar and
morgoth didn't call Sauron by that name during
the second age he called himself anatar so that's
like another different name that he had later on
during the first stage the cindar also called
him gorthar so that might have been what Adar
called him originally but I think because Sauron
was a mire just like Gandalf different people on
Middle Earth just had different names that they
gave him and then he makes a bunch of references
to the One Ring of Power because he says sauron's
true plan was to conquer the world creating power
over flesh in his failed attempts at Bridging
the gap between the scene and the Unseen World
The Wraith world like the world of pure magic
the thing that he was missing is meant to be
set up for his plan B so to speak to create the
rings of power because basically the one ring
of power does what Adar says Saron was trying to
do the secret fire that he mentions is the power
of a louvitar the one true God of The Lord of the
Rings Universe to create new life so he's talking
about the Orcs becoming this new race and having
a right to live just as much of a right to exist
as the other races on the planet whereas Galadriel
is like hardcore anti-oric I will eradicate every
single one of them to the last of my breath but he
winds up escaping during the chaos of the eruption
so remember we have two episodes left we'll see
what they do with him in the last two I think
there'll be some sort of Sauron versus Adar
scene when Sauron eventually does show up and
he'll probably wind up killing him himself like
it won't be Galadriel or one of the other good
characters to kill him it will be Sauron himself
to do the deed and because they're doing the Mount
Doom eruption so early maybe they will wind up
revealing who Sauron is in the finale like Sauron
face reveal at 10 million subs or at the end of
the finale and obviously this whole heart to heart
scene with Halbrand and Galadriel is meant to
be very ship worthy like there's supposed to be
some Sparks here like is there something going on
between the two of them but also his conversation
with her sounds very sorry it's like he makes
a couple references to Sauron related things
he talks about binding her his feeling to himself
which is exactly what Sauron does with the rings
of power like all the different rings are bound
to the one ring and thus to him and also when he
winds up meeting Bronwyn in the other southlanders
they ask him are you our true king and he's like
yes I am and it's just happened so quickly the
moment was kind of weird the way they pulled it
off and if you remember evil guy waldred was also
saying our true king will come his name is Sauron
so it is always possible he could be a version
of Sauron I'm not expecting it right now like
I need a little bit more evidence before I say
definitely but this whole scene of him calling
himself their true king could have a double
meaning like I am your true king but not the
One You're Expecting they reveal that waldridge
stole the sword activated the damn with it and
obviously that sets off Mount Doom and we find
out what the Orcs tunnel was for the whole time
it was just meant to be a pathway for the lake
to flow into the mountain and here's the reason
why the sky is always blotted out into present
day like thousands of years later there still is
no sun one that comes into Mordor is because
even after this the water continues flowing
from its original cource into the mountain so it
continually spews Ash into the sky for thousands
of years so this way it seems like it's always
dark in Mordor if you could Dam up the river and
stop it from flowing into the mountain then
you could probably stop it from spewing Ash
and eventually you could terraform the land back
into what it looks like now before it turned into
Mordor but that's like something that would take
them hundreds of years into the fourth age after
they kill Sauron when a reindeer suggests that
Theo throw away the sword by giving it to the
new minorians that's kind of what happens during
the war of the last Alliance like okay give the
one ring of power to this numenorian as silver
here we'll have him throw it away and that had
a very similar outcome because we find out that
wall grid stole the sword so they can't destroy it
and isildur couldn't throw the One Ring of Power
into Mount Doom so it just continued to exist so
even after waldridge uses it to activate the damn
device here it's still around like it could still
be picked up by someone and used as a regular
sword but the whole idea in episode 7 next week
is a it seems like they're just going to deal
with the aftermath of Mount Doom blowing up it
starts to look actually like hell the Elven word
for hell is basically the title of the episode
we'll probably find out what happened with Adar
where he ran off to it looks like they continue
to tease the balrog of khazad dum because they
keep talking about the mithril and Mining too
deeply and it also seems like the hard foots are
getting closer to the Southlands with Meteor Man
I am sure there'll be a billion more Sauron
references in next week's episode but I'm not
expecting any kind of reveal till either like
the very end of the finale or they might even
save it for season two but it would kind of suck
if they save it for season two like please let
us know who he is at least if you spotted any
other Easter eggs or references in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video just write
down below in the comments it is based on all
the evidence we've seen so far let me know who you
think that Sauron is or if we haven't seen him yet
and it'll be like somebody totally different
who will just show up later my Full House of
the Dragon episode 7 video will post on Sunday
after they release it be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that everyone
click here for my Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer
video to learn about you Jackman and coming back
and click here for my house of the Dragon episode
7 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!